some nevadans have quite a bit more
money tonight following the selection of
the first round of what's called winners
for the vax nevada days thanks for
joining us i'm brian loftis
and i'm denise valdez more than 200
winners were selected tonight
the goal of the incentive program is to
encourage more nevadans to get the copic
19 vaccine
orco mana joins us live with a look at
the winners hi there orca
well brian and denise max nevada days
has a total of five
million dollars in cash and prizes to
give out
over the next several weeks tonight the
first round of winners were announced
but you have to get the cover 19 vaccine
to be eligible
a special surprise for getting her shot
elizabeth alder winning 250
thousand dollars in cash the biggest
prize on the first of eight
vacs nevada days this is the first time
i've ever won anything
she was eligible for the money because
she got the covet 19 vaccine
alder calling her husband overwhelmed
with emotion
we live paycheck to paycheck i do i have
student loans that i have to pay off and
it's just going to be nice
to know that i can do that this
kindergarten teacher sharing why she got
vaccinated i wanted to be with my kids
fifteen-year-old keana butler who just
got her second dose thursday winning 50
thousand dollars in tuition money
this is just great because it gives me
the opportunity to actually think about
going to college now that's like one of
my main goals i've always wanted to
killing and harming people
this man barging in on the celebration
with anti-vaccine rhetoric
this vaccine is saving lives but even
with monetary incentives nevada's
vaccination rates are lagging i asked
the governor about those who still won't
get their shot
how do you reach out to them if this
isn't going to work well we're reaching
out every way possible we're making it
more convenient for everybody to get the
vaccine by bringing in the neighborhoods
with the pop-up sites
as that work continues alder is planning
her first purchase
buy my mom and dad a car because i don't
have one
now the drawings will happen every
thursday until august 26
where the grand prize winner of one
million dollars will be announced then
we also want to make it clear
that the winners were notified that they
won earlier but they weren't told the
amount they won
until the actual event reporting live in
the newsroom tonight orco mana 8 news
now